DEREK DOWNEY: Hi.
I'm Derek Downey, a developer
advocate for Google Cloud.
In the last video, I
highlighted different options
for controlling the
database behavior
for my banking application that
I'm deploying to Cloud Spanner.
In this video, I'm going to
show how Spanner organizes data
into splits and how that impacts
the design of the database
schema.
I will also highlight the
tools available in Spanner
for efficient schema
design and how
to keep the schema updated
with online schema changes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
To start, Cloud Spanner is a
role-based relational database.
Spanner requires
a defined schema
and supports
standard SQL concepts
for defining that schema.
Table columns must have
a data type defined.
Spanner supports standard
scalar data types, as well as
more advanced data types to
enable different application
requirements.
For instance, JSON allows
storing schema-less data
within Spanner.
Constraints, foreign
keys, and unique indexes
help enforce the
integrity of the data,
and unique and nonunique
indexes help provide
faster lookups of the data.
A key reason to use Spanner
is the near unlimited scaling
capability for
application workloads.
When designing that schema,
it's important to understand
how Spanner organizes data
to achieve the scalability.
As a horizontally
scaling database,
Spanner automatically
shards data into splits.
Splits enable Spanner
to scale by distributing
compute capacity to
multiple servers.
But how do these splits
affect the design decisions
for my schema?
For a quick example
from my banking app,
I have a Customers table with
a CustomerId as primary key.
A common pattern in many
relational databases
is to increment an
integer for new rows.
With data splits,
sequential keys
are an antipattern
because your last split
will receive all new
rows, creating a hot spot.
Ideally, the primary key should
be inserted in random order
so inserts hit multiple splits,
which improves right-scaling.
Common methods to get
random order inserts
are UUID version 4 or
generating hash keys.
Splits also have
implications for related data
in other tables.
In my app, a customer can
have multiple accounts.
The accounts data could
end up in a different split
than the customer it belongs to.
If I have a query to get a
customer and their accounts,
Spanner will have to get
data from multiple splits.
This increases request latency,
especially if the splits are
processed by different servers.
To avoid this, tables can
be interleaved together
in the schema definition.
If I interleave Accounts
into the Customers table,
then the account rows will
be located in the same split
as the customer they belong
to and make my query faster.
Keep in mind that interleaving
cannot be changed for existing
tables and not all table
relationships should be
interleaved.
Interleaving should be used for
related data that is frequently
accessed together.
Splits also affect indexes
because Spanner implements
indexes as tables internally,
so requesting more columns
than an index provides
can result in getting data
from multiple splits.
Creating an index
that stores columns
that are typically requested
by queries can solve this.
In my app, the
UniqueUsername index
also stores the
password so a login
query that searches for
a combination of username
and password will
be done efficiently.
The last thing to highlight
about Spanner schema design
is that schema
changes are online,
so your application can
continue reading and writing
to the table during the change.
The time to complete a change
depends on the type of change.
Adding a new column that
doesn't have a default value
will complete quickly
since there's nothing
to do for existing rows.
Adding a new column or
modifying an existing column
with a default value
requires backfilling data
into each existing
row of the table.
Modifying an existing column
with a new constraint,
such as NOT NULL, will
require data validation.
Data validation and
backfilling operations
take longer to
complete, but Spanner
will process this
in the background
so that your users and
applications are not impacted.
This makes schema
changes painless.
As a relational
database, Spanner
requires a defined schema
using supported data types,
constraints, and indexing.
But it makes it as easy as
possible to change later
as data requirements change.
Data in Spanner is
automatically sharded
into splits that can be powered
by different compute nodes
to achieve great scalability.
Splits require different
schema design choices
than traditional relational
database systems,
and I've shown how
to avoid hot-spotting
and how to interleave
related data together
so query requests are
handled efficiently.
In the final video, I will
show how our banking app uses
both standard DML statements
and Spanner mutations to write
to our Spanner database.
[MUSIC PLAYING]